IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE AND MAKE
S NOT A PROBLEM
AGAINST COLUMBUS.
THE SAVE MY JEAN-FRANCOIS MAGIC
YORENNIAL BOAT
RECEIVER, THAT IS FOR SURE.
ALEKSANDER BARKOV .AND  HERE
COMES COLUMBUS BLUE JACKETS .
.  AND
PANTHER POWER. ED
BUT
CASEY MAKE A REALLY GOOD JOB
AND UNDER DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND COACH ANDREW BRUNETTE HAS
DONE EVERYTHING    ONE OF
THOSE LONG-TERM 8 YEAR DEALS?
WE WILL SEE THIS SUMMER.
THE
SHOT. AND THE BLUE JACKETS ARE
AND BOONE JENNNNER . AND I THOU
REMAINING.
CAN HAVE SOME MOMENTS OF
POSITIVITY.
I CAN PROVIDE SOME MOMENTUM. SO
BRING THAT POINT OF ATTACK.
YOU CAN SEE JUST HE SWINGS DOWN
THAT FAR SIDE.
LOOK AT THE TOU
BARKOV.
GOING RIGHT TO JONATHAN
HUBERDEAU DOWN LOW.
BUT NOT QUITE TWISTER.
FROM TH THEY ARE TAKING THAT
BOARD.
>> John: 5-2. TWO QUICK ONES.TO
HUBERDEAU CANNOT GET IT.
IT DOWN ON THE ICE . IS
HIS 12, THIRD PERIOD.
GOAL OF THE YEAR.
THE EIGHTH GOAL OF THIS IT TOUC
TO THE BACK.
GAME.
AND HE ALMOST DOES>> Cassie: TH
TO MOVE THE HOCKEYCOULD
MacKENZIE WEEGAR A SHOT .GOES B
AND AROUND.
AND HE CANNOT FIND HIS